there is more bad news for Florida
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis Ron
DeSantis as he is on his Asia tour while
there is a flooding recovery happening
in Florida that includes long gas lines
the santises in Asia like a bobble head
as we saw earlier this week and he is
now getting sued by Disney World I have
been saying for weeks
Rhonda santis is over playing his hand
with the anti-woke stuff and Ron
DeSantis is really overplaying his hand
with the anti-disney stuff and if you
think Dominion voting systems had good
attorneys representing them against Fox
News just wait until you see how good
Disney's attorneys are CNBC reports
Disney Sue's Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis alleges political effort to
hurt its business Walt Disney company
sued Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
alleging that the Republican Governor
has waged a quote Relentless campaign to
weaponize government power over the
company you know Republicans love to use
the word weaponize and in fact they are
holding they have been holding hearing
since taking over the House of
Representatives
about the weaponization of government
and the weaponization of big Tech and of
course the terms are completely and
wholly inappropriate in those instances
if we are to accurately and correctly
use the term weaponization it's hard to
think of a better example than what Ron
DeSantis has done with government power
against Walt Disney World as a
retaliatory action for Walt Disney World
saying we're against the don't say gay
Bill the article continues the suit
dramatically escalates the feud between
DeSantis who's expected to become a top
Republican contender in the 2024
presidential race and Disney the lawsuit
was filed the same day that a
desantis-backed board moved to undo a
development deal that it says Disney
struck to thwart its power this is going
to be
a wild ride
and we've been talking about how Trump's
existing indictment and possible future
indictments might interfere with his
presidential primary campaign DeSantis
hasn't even announced that he's running
yet we don't know if he will
increasingly the polling is shaky or
shakier and shakier but if he did is it
possible that the chaos in Florida will
become a distraction and an impediment
Disney's attorneys in all likelihood
have had drafts of this lawsuit ready to
go
since quite early on in this entire
Fiasco and as Ron DeSantis kept finding
new ways to yes weaponize Florida
government against Disney
they continued to add to those lawsuit
drafts they were waiting for the board
to vote and now that the board has voted
they are suing now I want to be really
clear because I know some of you are
going to write to me and say David it's
weird to see a progressive gleeful about
the Uber capitalist Corporation Walt
Disney World
folks this this is not about that I I
don't like Disney I I mean I've said
before I hate theme parks when I went to
Disney World it was just horrifying it
overpriced ridiculously overpriced
terrible food long lines and it I hate
all of it okay Walt Disney was an
anti-semite just disgust like I don't
like anything about Disney but if I step
back and look at the facts DeSantis is
in the wrong here from everything that
has been publicly reported obviously at
some point when we say well is he in the
wrong there has to be an adjudication we
have a lawsuit here and we may have a
version of that adjudication and this is
a crusade that I have been telling you
for a while really May backfire and even
though I don't like so there's the
socio-cultural part and then there's the
legal part on the socio-cultural part I
recognize that just because I can't
stand Disney World doesn't mean that
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
people absolutely love it and picking a
fight with Disney is potentially a
losing battle just at its face that's
number one and then number two as we've
said before
um aside from Disney specifically
the country for the most part is on the
woke side not the anti-woke side and you
know the the don't say gay bill was a
big part of the Disney controversy with
Ron DeSantis we had a recent poll which
asked Americans on the whole do you
think that Society has done too much not
enough or about the right amount when it
comes to protecting and whatever LGBT
folks and the balance was on we've done
the right amount or not enough in other
words the majority of the country
doesn't think that woke is going too far
or whatever phraseology the right wants
to apply to it so we'll see about the
legal aspect of it
um certainly when it comes to the
sociocultural in all sorts of different
ways Ron DeSantis seems to have
dramatically overstepped here we will
watch it but this is a crusade that may
well backfire
Tucker Carlson the fired Fox News
propagandist has resurfaced for the
first time and made the first statement
since his firing we're going to look at
it it's only a couple of minutes long
the funniest part of it is Tucker
dressed himself up like he still has a
job I don't know why I find that
hilarious he's probably wearing shorts
which is fine but he at least at the top
half of his body uh shirt and tie suit
jacket and the entire thing
it's almost like he's doing a monologue
at the top of his show except there's no
show because he's been fired so let's
listen to what he had to say he doesn't
really mention much about the firing
itself it's also funny knowing that he's
doing this from the multi-million dollar
Studio that he put in his house in order
to be able to do Fox News shows from
home
uh it's it's all just endlessly funny
but let's listen really a profile and
courage Tucker Carlson's first statement
since the firing here we go good evening
Carlson one of the first things he he
even starts as if he's still on Fox News
it's it's so good she realized when you
step outside the noise for a few days is
how many genuinely nice people there are
in this country kind and decent people
people who really care about what's true
and a bunch of hilarious people also a
lot of those it's got to be the majority
of the population right the majority of
the population is really really funny
hilarious people also a lot of those
it's got to be the majority of the
population even now so that's heartening
the other thing you notice when you take
a little time off is how unbelievably
stupid most of the debates you see on
television are yes but that
this is so funny he's been fired for
three days and he wants to act like the
biggest critic of the way that
television is produced his Network and
his the programs he's been on for for
decades at this point quite frankly
are the reason why we don't get
substantive debates on for-profit
television we don't get substantive
discussions it's because you've got a
cram in a four minute interview
in between commercials and Lindsey
Graham crying about something like he's
the
it's it's not an incorrect diagnosis but
he's the one who caused the illness in
the first place to a great degree
they're completely irrelevant mean
nothing true in five years we won't even
remember that we had them trust me as
someone who's participated
and yet at the same time and this is the
amazing thing the undeniably big topics
the ones that will Define our future get
virtually no discussion at all that's
true but that applies to his own program
now my guest now he's saying with the
benefit of hindsight you know I had no
choice they had me over a barrel or
whatever the case may be it's all you've
got to read between the lines but it's a
guy who is responsible for the status
quo
pretending to take the moral High Ground
like he's a victim of it or civil
liberties emerging science demographic
change corporate Power by the way
demographic change means you remember
when he said brown people come in and
make us dirtier and poorer
that's what he's talking about and
trying to whitewash here special
resources
when was the last time you heard a
legitimate debate about any of those
issues it's been a long time debates
like that are not permitted in American
Media both political parties and their
donors have reached consensus on what
benefits them and they actively collude
to shut down any conversation about it
suddenly the United States looks very
much like a one-party State huh
depressing realization but it's not
permanent our current orthodoxies won't
last they're brain dead nobody actually
believes them hardly anyone's life is
improved by them this moment is two
inherently ridiculous to continue and so
it won't
the people in charge know this that's
why they're hysterical and aggressive
they're afraid they've given up
persuasion they're resorting to force
now I want to make another Point here
and then I will listen to the last 30
seconds without another interruption
you as a an informed consumer of media
you know people who listen to my show
it's obviously a self-selected group
it's not random people I know many of
you because you wrote to me and you
responded to my tweets about this video
many of you are confused about what the
hell Tucker Carlson is talking about now
in short he's basically
without directly saying it he's saying
that the Deep state uniparty that
controls Democrats and Republicans has
silenced him because he wanted to talk
about the big issues of our time and
nobody would let them talk about it or
whatever
but understand that if you who follow
all of these different conspiracies and
ideas if you're confused by what the
hell Tucker Carlson is talking about
imagine his audience they don't have a
clue what this is about they it's it's
the the exact type of thing Trump does
where he talks about things no one
really understands because he's
deliberately either con he's either
deliberately obfuscating or confused but
it doesn't matter because it's a cult
that follows him but it won't work when
honest people say what's true calmly and
without embarrassment they become
powerful whoa at the same time the Liars
who've been trying to silence them
shrink and they become weaker that's the
iron law of the universe true things
Prevail doesn't seem like it where can
you still find Americans saying true
things
there aren't many places left but there
are some and that's enough
as long as you can hear the words there
is hope
see you soon there you go so now if
you're saying what is that a statement
about the firing it doesn't sound like
it has anything to do with the firing
you have to read between the lines and
so when you read between the lines and
he talks about the Yuna party that's
really in power it's not Democrats or
Republicans when he talks about there
are great forces that don't want us to
have the serious conversations we need
to have a lot of what's in the media is
stupid and all these different things
he's essentially saying
um Fox News is part of the problem it's
not about left right there's like some
kind of Greater Elite that is in charge
and controlling everything and they want
to silence me and they want to silence
you and all of these sort of things so
on the Practical matters what is Tucker
Carlson's most likely next stop uh
I think the most profitable thing would
be his own Venture and hilariously
because of the text messages that were
released as a result of the Dominion
voting systems lawsuit we know that one
of his former producers was actually
engaged in texting with him I believe it
was a producer uh about hey you know
what if we like start our own thing and
we could make this much from the podcast
and we could make this this much from
the website and so on and so forth
particularly at this point in time it
seems to me that Tucker's most
profitable move long term would be to
start his own thing and control all of
the revenue the easier thing and I can
tell you this is someone who I you know
I'm running the entire thing here and
and so on and so forth uh the easier
thing although maybe less profitable
would be just to get hired by someone
like would Newsmax hire Tucker they
probably would would it be as profitable
as if he built up his own entity no but
he wouldn't have to worry about any of
that logistical stuff and he could just
talk to the camera and get a paycheck so
I don't know where he will will end up
but it does seem the most lucrative
option would be to launch his own thing
he's got a lot of followers and people
who
would just send you know people send a
billionaire Trump money because he says
I need money and they don't think twice
about it they will obviously send Tucker
money as well so that's it uh Tucker
Carlson uh you know respectfully getting
dressed up as if he still has a show and
uh delivering a two-minute monologue
about
how I guess everybody else is bad and
he's good and he'll tell you the truth
we will continue to follow the Tucker
Saga we will take a quick break and be
back right after this
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
all right this is very serious stuff the
Donald Trump rape trial is underway in
New York and it is not getting nearly
the attention that it likely deserves
we're going to go over a few of the
headlines a few of the articles but this
this is very serious stuff and very
graphic stuff is happening in this trial
uh the guardian has an article Donald
Trump raped me writer E Gene Carroll
testifies in New York Court this is now
under oath in court
advice columnist says former president
quote shattered my reputation and says
alleged attack left her unable to enjoy
romantic life Carol testified in her
civil lawsuit seeking damages for
battery after Trump allegedly sexually
assaulted her in a New York Department
Store changing room in 1996 and for
defamation after he accused her of lying
and perpetrating a hoax when she went
public with her accusations in a book
quote under oath to the jury from Eugene
Carroll and there are no cameras in the
courtroom so while we have are these
reports quote I'm here because Donald
Trump raped me and when I wrote about it
he said it didn't happen he lied and
shattered my reputation I'm here to try
and get my life back
before Carol testified judge Lewis
Kaplan warned Trump may have crossed the
line into jury tampering after the
former president posted an attack on his
social media site truth social calling
Carol's accusations a made-up scam and a
Witch Hunt we're going to look at those
posts in a moment a Politico article
also explains the details of the alleged
event Carol a magazine columnist has
accused Trump of sexually assaulting her
in a dressing room of luxury department
store Bergdorf Goodman in the mid 90s
and then indeed there is a yahoo news
article
from Yahoo News Canada
which goes into the graphic detail that
e Gene Carroll revealed
under oath talking about the sixth floor
lingerie department
a lacy bodysuit that Trump jokingly
suggested she try on
um
and it includes all sorts of graphic
details that I don't know that
necessarily need to go into but they are
they are quite violent now Donald
Trump's reaction to this he went on
Truth social
and he posted the following these are
the posts that could be considered
tampering quote the E Gene Carroll case
Ms Bergdorf Goodman is a made-up scam
her lawyer is a political operative
financed by a big political donor that
they said didn't exist only to get
caught lying about that just look at her
CNN interview before and after the
commercial break like a different person
she said there was a dress using the old
Monica Lewinsky stuff then she didn't
want to produce it the dress should be
allowed to be part of the case this is a
fraudulent and false story Witch Hunt
then continuing in a second post to
Troth quote they got caught lying the
Miss Berg going from Ms to miss Bergdorf
Goodman case is financed by a big
political donor that they tried to hide
does anybody believe that I would take a
then almost 60 year old woman that I
didn't know from the front door of a
very crowded department store with me
being very well known to put it mildly
into a tiny dressing room and her she
didn't scream there are no Witnesses
nobody saw this she never made a police
complaint if I was seen there with a
woman big press scam now aside from the
facts of this case which are slowly uh
being asserted in court this is not even
close to the only sexual assault
allegation against Donald Trump not by a
long shot we're talking about dozens of
such allegations including from one of
Donald Trump's own Ex-Wives now we could
mention many of them but one particular
allegation of note
relates to a lawsuit filed in 2016 by a
woman under the name Jane Doe against
Donald Trump which accused Trump of
raping her when she was 13 years old
in 1994 this lawsuit which I've
mentioned to you before was filed in New
York it was dismissed in 2017 by a judge
who said the allegations aren't specific
enough and the accuser later withdrew
the lawsuit reportedly because of the
threats to her and her family's safety
Trump of course has repeatedly denied
those allegations and has said that they
are quote false and ridiculous so where
is the E Gene Carroll case going
remember there are two parts to this
there's the defamation allegation
against Trump there is also the actual
assault allegation which can be brought
despite traditional statutes of
limitations because of a particular New
York law that says if you didn't we
which opens up a window for filing such
cases
even if the statute of limitations has
expired if you didn't previously bring
the allegation forward I have no idea in
the world what is going to happen with
this case there were questions about
whether Trump would even be in the
courtroom so far he has not been he has
an event in New Hampshire later today
which we will cover live which certainly
puts him closer to New York than Florida
does but at this point no indication
that he plans to be there uh Marjorie
Taylor green radical republican
congresswoman
said yesterday that Tucker Carlson's
filing uh firing by Fox News was illegal
now she doesn't use the word illegal but
it's really important to understand when
these people on the right say that was a
violation of the First Amendment
they are saying that it is against the
law what took place we're going to look
at a video clip of Marjorie Taylor green
explaining I guess her perspective if
you can call it that what is really
important to understand is that when she
says Tucker's First Amendment rights
were violated by Fox News she's saying
it was an illegal firing these are the
people who hold as one of their most
important stated values low business
regulation let businesses do what they
want to do Law and Order
um we we need to unburden businesses
from government limitations they should
be allowed to do what is best and most
profitable for them and here she says a
firing by a private company
was unconstitutional and therefore
against the law we're going to break it
all down let's take a listen big news of
the week Fox fired Tucker Carlson
um fox has gone left they've gone woke
we're clearly calling them out for
Tucker is a great voice for
conservatives across the country he
doesn't have the platform anymore will
you weigh in on Fox's decision to fire
probably one of the more conservative
voices most important voices in America
absolutely I think it was devastating to
our first amendment Eric I see it as a
very serious problem our first amendment
is Free Speech but it's also freedom of
press and when a gigantic Media company
like Fox News fires their number one uh
Tucker Carlson not for him doing
anything wrong not because his ratings
were bad but they literally fired him
because they caved to the woke mob now
that's completely untrue
Tucker Carlson caused a
multi hundred million if not
multi-billion dollar problem for Fox
News Fox News made this decision based
on money Not only was Tucker's program
partially responsible for the news
coverage that got them sued by dominion
and smartmatic and so far led to a
nearly 800 million dollar lawsuit uh
settlement uh rather in favor of
dominion he also is being sued by a
former staffer for alleged
discrimination and sexism and so on and
so forth behind the scenes
he potentially will have caused another
lawsuit by Ray Epps that may be
forthcoming it this was a financial
thing but that's not the focus of this
segment it's marjorie's misunderstanding
of the First Amendment what we're seeing
is we're seeing the end of the first
amendment that's how I see it I can't
see it any other way we've seen
censorship out of control we we saw the
federal government Department of
Homeland Security aligned with big Tech
to censor Americans uh for several years
now on political issues because they
weren't speaking the speech that was the
chosen speech to say well neither was
Tucker Carlson Tucker Carlson was
pushing the limit every single night on
his show and he was telling the news
stories that the American people wanted
to hear I also want to point out that
many Democrats even watch Tucker Carlson
okay sure so the question here is is
there any way in which a company firing
an employee could violate the First
Amendment the way Marjorie Taylor green
says the First Amendment of the
Constitution
to the Constitution protects
uh individuals
and in theory companies as well
from government actions that interfere
with freedom of speech religion press
assembly and petition
private companies private companies are
not bound by the first amendment in the
same way and on the other hand
um they also generally have the right to
set their own rules and policies this is
something that people like Marjorie
Taylor green on the right claim to
Revere as one of the highest goals and
and virtues of the United States legal
system
and this applies to employment as well
now could firings be illegal sure
there's all sorts of wrongful
termination that that can and often is
argued by by employees uh if Tucker were
to be fired because he's white or
because he's Christian certainly he
would have a very good case for wrongful
termination uh I don't believe it would
have anything to do with the First
Amendment it would violate employer
non-discrimination law but the idea that
because they fired Tucker the First
Amendment isn't violated merely because
Tucker spoke on TV is ridiculous it's
ridiculous and it shouldn't even be you
know the sad thing is that we have to
explain it in this way now is there any
way is there any way where a company
could be violating the First Amendment
rights of an employee imagine that an
employee speaks out about a matter of
public concern as a citizen and their
speech isn't related to their job duties
in any way
you can try to argue that your first
amendment rights were violated it's very
tough to do if it's a government job
it's slightly easier to do but it's a
tough it's a tough uh standard to reach
some states have laws that protect
employees above and beyond the First
Amendment like for example some states
have laws that prohibit employers from
retaliating against employees for
political activity outside of work so
that would be a situation where there's
an additional protection and the
employee would be able to
um hold their employer to account do any
of these circumstances even remotely
apply to Fox News firing Tucker Carlson
not absolutely not absolutely not and so
we are faced once again with this
question do right-wingers not actually
know what the First Amendment does and
what it is or do they know but they
realize their followers don't
and so they blatantly lie to them on TV
I don't know you be the judge but what
we do know is Marjorie Taylor green is
humiliatingly wrong here
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today I'm going to be speaking with Max
Burns who's an award-winning Democratic
strategist and also founder of third
degree strategies Max recently wrote an
article asserting that we may we may
finally be at a Tipping Point when it
comes to gun violence and gun safety in
the United States we're going to talk
about that Max great to have you on I
appreciate it thanks so much for having
me so I mean listen my audience knows
we've heard this so many times before
this we this is definitely a Tipping
Point you know Sandy Hook was a Tipping
Point or Pulse Nightclub or whatever
else the case may be even popular
reforms like uh a background check as a
requirement for any gun transaction
including Private person-to-person Sales
very popular with the American public
after Sandy Hook can't get it done so I
think people would be right to be
skeptical that we are now at a Tipping
Point so late out for us why now what
has changed
well you're absolutely right I think the
gun violence conversation has been one
that's been littered with
disappointments from the beginning but
what we're seeing now is a really
interesting Confluence of factors one is
that even though Congress is essentially
useless on gun policy right now we're
seeing a real golden age of democratic
lawmakers in States passing legislation
that would have been unimaginable even a
few years ago Gretchen Whitmer for
example uh just passed an 11 Bill gun
reform package that would have ended her
career back in 2008 now they're talking
about her as a potential candidate for
president the other side of this is the
NRA they are in free fall and what was
once the biggest gun rights group in
America can now barely afford to keep
the lights on in its office much less
fund the candidates that have distorted
this conversation for decades so there's
this this unique window of weakness on
the right and strength on the left
that's really create getting a unique
space for a gun conversation that leads
to actual legislation
I think a couple of the difficulties are
and part of this relates to what is or
could be done at the federal level and
what is or could be done at the state
level
a lot of this right now for example when
you talk about the Gretchen Whitmer
package we're talking about the state
level and here there's a sort of like
moral hazard situation where the state's
most willing to deal with this stuff
often are the ones that already are kind
of ahead on the stricter side when it
comes to gun safety as it is so then
when we think about well how do we deal
with this issue in South Carolina or
Texas we start to think federally and
one of the difficulties about federal
gun safety legislation is that running
on it for National candidates often
isn't a great idea from a strategy
perspective which I would be glad to let
you speak to as well but we there's this
idea and maybe it's true maybe it's not
that when you run National campaigns
including for like Senate right because
you you're in DC but your constituents
are in your state that when you talk
about gun safety regulations you rarely
bring new voters to support you but you
often activate people who disagree with
you and so there's that difficulty of
saying well the way to get Texas and
West Virginia and South Carolina to do
something is to go Federal but
campaigning on this stuff federally
often backfires so how do you do that
yeah I think that's a great point and
one of the interesting challenges here
is that for years Democrats were sort of
bought into this Republican message that
it was political suicide to talk about
guns in a campaign right I remember
following the Virginia Tech shooting
Democrats came out the day after to
publicly reassure America that they
wouldn't dream of passing any gun
control legislation uh and now those
same people are leading major campaigns
in States and federally on gun reform
and that's in large part due to the rise
of groups like every town Moms Demand
Action these new groups that have sort
of adopted the rights organizing
approach for this and we see that now
that the majority of Americans have in
some way been touched by gun violence
numbers in support of gun reformer at
record highs and we're seeing that
really start to break down the old
Coalition in Tennessee the Republican
Governor Lee is supporting red flag
legislation in Utah the Republican
Governor alongside every town passed a
bunch of gun reforms that make it
tougher to get a gun and require
background checks that's a coalition
that was unimaginable even a few years
ago that Republicans are seeing the
pressure mount and actually realizing
it's safer to take incremental guns
safety steps this is a completely
different landscape than I think
Republicans are used to playing in and
it's one where Democrats can actually
talk about guns and find that people are
agreeing with them for the first time
since 1994. what is the timeline on
which you think we could see action on
some of these areas
I think it's much quicker than than we
think if we're looking at States the
more that we've organized and this is a
really key part of every town is they
are funding State races they're cheaper
they have a bigger impact on actual
legislation and we're seeing that start
to create a momentum for National change
once red states which are
disproportionately affected by gun
violence have seen that these things
work they're actually pretty excited to
talk about them and that's something
that we're seeing distorted by the gun
lobby but when voters go to the polls
they are voting on this issue it's a big
reason why you see Joe Biden has gone
from saying he won't talk about social
issues at all in 2024 to opening with an
ad that talks heavily about gun violence
Democrats can see it's a winning issue
and they're for once really finding
their voice here
we have in the United States sort of
three separate gun issues you have mass
shootings you have individual homicides
affecting one or two individuals per
incident and then you have suicides
using firearms in thinking about and the
the prescriptions would be different for
these three different categories if we
think about mass shootings for a moment
I've put out a list of 10 or 12
different ideas that would never
eliminate every mass shooting but would
certainly do something to reduce the
number and there are some trends that we
see when it comes to the mass shootings
age of the shooter typically under 25
type of firearm used often an assault
style rifle you know there's these
trends that we start to see what's the
lowest hanging fruit in your mind that
would blend the most effective changes
that could be made with ones that are
most likely to actually be politically
viable
well I think there's this unique moment
here that we see with Tennessee with
Utah with North Dakota that's talking
about raising the age for gun ownership
uh that you combine background checks
which we've seen even in in Michigan was
a hugely popular thing Universal
background check used to be a consensus
Republican position in the Bush
Administration they have gone so far off
on that that it doesn't resemble
anything Americans want but you combine
that background check legislation and
red flag legislation and you have
immediately handled two of the most
vulnerable populations people who are
going to use their guns for violence
against others knowingly at the time
they buy the gun and people who are
going to use it for self-harm
disproportionately young people and in
rural communities in agricultural
communities huge rates of gun suicide
and it all has to do with gun access and
we can talk about making sure guns
aren't in the hands of kids without
talking about these Republican
conspiracies of stealing everyone's guns
away and we're finding that the space
for that conversation is getting bigger
every year when it comes to the next
um what's remaining I guess I would say
of the Biden first term and you know
we'll see if whether there's a second
term in sort of what framing he uses for
for the 2024 campaign given the
circumstances in in the House and Senate
Republicans controlling the house uh
Democrats controlling the Senate at this
point
what's your sense of at the federal
level what might be possible you know I
understand you're saying that Senate
Republican I'm sorry that state
Republicans to some degree uh seem more
willing to take action what about things
that would have to go through the House
and Senate
so that's the really big sticking point
here is that Republicans have already
said that the bipartisan gun bill that
they gave Joe Biden is it for them they
do not want any more so it's going to be
basically a status quo situation until
voters in 2024 can be heard yeah and one
of the reassuring things we're seeing is
that just in the same way that Beltway
Consultants said don't talk about
abortion in 2022 it'll be polarizing but
that turned out to be one of the leading
issues for voters we're seeing the same
thing now with guns and it's one reason
why Joe Biden who is as I'm sure you
would agree very risk-averse is
comfortable opening his re-election
campaign talking about gun violence
do you have any insights and this is
getting very specific now you know
there's something we can look at the gun
safety issue mental health video games
all the stuff that is always thrown
around but there is something intangible
maybe about American Gun culture that
doesn't exist in some of the other
countries with relatively High rates of
gun ownership wherein I don't know it's
just sort of like it's more common in
the US that someone would see Firearms
as a way to solve a personal problem an
interpersonal problem a societal problem
that doesn't seem to be the case in many
other countries
is there anything that can be done to
restructure that relationship between
Americans and guns which seems to be
sort of like a layer that's above all
the policy that could be put in place
there is I mean it's fundamentally a
constitutional issue I'm old enough to
remember when people were blaming video
games for violence but the problem has
always been that guns in this country
often have more rights than the people
they're killing and the fact is they the
position has moved to such a maximalist
one on the right that doesn't reflect
anything even a few years ago that the
Court held uh on guns there's now
essentially Republicans arguing for an
unlimited right to own any gun that you
want and they're saying that anyone even
Republicans who propose Common Sense
limits are against democracy and against
the Constitution and it's polarizing
people to violence because when you're
told your fundamental rights are being
taken by a tyrannical government that
justifies almost anything in order to
protect your rights and we're seeing
that happen I mean we're seeing former
Mega voters in Nevada who shot at
elected officials they thought were
stealing an election question until the
Supreme Court or congress gets some
constitutional momentum to rethink The
Madness of our current interpretation of
the Second Amendment it's tough to get
anything long-term accomplished last
thing I want to ask you about I have
heard from many uh progressives
including friends of mine but also
people who just call into my show who
Express views very similar to mine on
the issue of gun safety and and what
they would like to see but also don't
like the idea of the right Wingers being
the only ones with the guns and so they
have armed themselves particularly in
the last few years they have become
Progressive gun owners gladly willing to
subject themselves to background check
mental health eval liability insurance
all the things we would want to put in
but they don't like the idea of the
right Wingers being the ones who
disproportionately have the guns have
you seen this have you heard it is it a
race to the bottom or neurological
reaction to what we're seeing out in the
world oh I've absolutely Heard It In
fact I believe the fastest growing group
of gun owners is black women and they're
doing this in response to the increasing
racial polarization and race-baiting on
the right and I'll tell you one thing
that is sure to get us into the courts
is the idea of black people owning guns
is not something Republicans consider to
be the Second Amendment we saw that with
philando Castile who was an NRA member
that they did not stand up for at all
the quickest way that we can get to a
meaningful gun reform conversation is
for Republicans to get scared at all of
the non-republicans who are buying guns
but it's I to me a completely rational
response and it's a sign of government
policy failure that people feel the need
to have multiple guns to protect
themselves from their own government's
inability to act to protect them that we
should be ashamed of that
we are going to link to Max's piece
about this issue we've been speaking
with Max Burns who's a democratic
strategist and also founder of third
degree strategies Max really appreciate
your time and insights today
much
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman and show remember to support us
on patreon go to patreon.com
davidpackman show where you can get
access to behind the scenes videos The
Daily bonus show the commercial free
Daily Show as well as special discounts
on merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpackman show one
of the other ways you can tell that the
2024 election is really getting going in
Earnest is the frequency with which
attack ads are being released we looked
at a Ron DeSantis ad we looked at a
trump ad we looked at a pack ad all
sorts of different ads lately a failed
form of President Donald Trump has now
released such a ridiculously dangerous
ad uh that it's hard to believe anyone
would even fall for this but it's being
released for a reason and it's because
Trump knows his audience they this ad
that Trump put out yesterday it's about
90 seconds 100 seconds long it invokes
multiple conspiracy theories it attacks
a trans woman
um it's really really insane stuff let's
take a look at it it's an invasion of
America
streets flooded with poison killing
Millions enemies and tyrants on opposite
sides of the globe laugh at us
[Music]
the threat to nuclear Annihilation once
forgotten is now real again
America's weakness has become their
strength the global elitist okay so you
have to understand that the visual
components here are a big part of this
the great reset just appeared on the
screen that's that's uh the these what
deep state folks love to talk about the
great reset they love to demonize the
world economic Forum they had statistics
on screen about fentanyl seized at the
border now of course you might say to
yourself well if they're seizing the
fentanyl then it's not getting into the
country right like isn't that a good
sign that that our border patrol is
doing a good job by saying they don't
care it's all conjecture it's all
propaganda it's all performative send
your kids to war who tell you a woman is
a man and a man is a woman okay and at
this point they put trans woman Dylan
Mulvaney at least I think that's who
this is up on the screen they tell you a
man is a woman and a woman is a man this
is completely ridiculous when it comes
to policy as we've talked about before
they are dramatically overplaying their
hand nationally on this issue but within
the Maga right just being anti-trans for
the hell of it is playing really well
these are Big Applause lines when they
do events in public teach your children
their country their faith their beliefs
are a lie they have corrupted every
facet of American government webinar
against you while they watch our Cities
Burn in violent crimes Skyrocket you and
your families pay the price remember
long term
crime is down violent crime is down the
murder rate is down long term there have
been shorter term uh spikes some of
which happened under Trump
and as we will talk about on the program
tomorrow
the red states of the United States are
dramatically more violent than the blue
States out of control inflation and
economy wrecked now remember out of the
unemployment rate is extraordinarily low
job creation is high inflation has been
high it has now declined consecutively
for many many months under Joe Biden
every it's hard to go five seconds
without finding lies which is sort of
the way it is under with a trump speech
as well a nation in Decline this is Joe
Biden's America
failing weak but one man one movement
can change all that for us put America
the middle class first and put the
globalists the elitist and the corrupt
in their place bring back pride and the
American dream to let the world know
don't mess with us one man focused on
the true owners of this great land one
movement focused on the true priorities
make America great for us again
okay
that's a trumpet
you might think is that a trailer to
some dystopian movie is that a satire is
that an SNL skit No that's actually a
trump ad including three times in the
hundred seconds the same video of when
Joe Biden tripped walking up to Air
Force One three times that's included
up and then riddled with corrosive and
destructive lies I guess if there's any
praise that we can give there's any
Silver Lining here it's the ad doesn't
include lies about who won in 2020 with
that is the is that something that we
could find as a redeeming quality here
if you knew someone who said this stuff
to you in person right the the arguments
if you can even call them that that this
ad makes if you went to a dinner party
and someone rattled off what this ad
says to you you might say do you need a
psyche vowel is this someone who has
become completely delusional and is
experiencing a paranoid delusional uh
event or state to the point that they
need to be evaluated because it is so
disconnected from reality
but this is all they have they've
abandoned policy notice that there's no
policy proposals there it's trans people
are bad and Biden's bad and world war
three you know but there's no actual
policy proposals there so this is all
they have this is my expectation maybe
not so much about what the primary will
be like because remember Trump hasn't
won the Primary yet he probably will he
hasn't won it yet but he's already
campaigning against Joe Biden in the
primary maybe they'll have to pretend to
talk about policy although maybe not but
we can already see that it's going to be
a general election once again where
whoever is the Republican nominee will
not utter a word about policy and it's
because they have lost on policy all
right I meant to get this earlier in the
week didn't have time but it is very
interesting over the weekend Donald
Trump spoke to a sycophant crowd in Fort
Myers Florida this was the Lee County
Republican party event and it was
completely Bonkers now maybe the one
moment where we questioned whether the
crowd was as sycophantic as we believed
them to be was when Trump in uh insulted
I guess we would say or went after
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis there was
muted Applause at this moment but Trump
pulling out the standard grievances
about DeSantis during this this event
and again it's a Florida Republican
crowd friendlier to DeSantis and there
was only a smattering of Applause I got
1.2 million more votes than your
successful Governor's campaign you know
that we got 1.2 million
sure I'd love to have your support sir
I'd love to have your support I'm down
at about three I'd love to have your
support sir let's think about it then
there was like a rocket ship after I
gave it otherwise right now you'd have a
lawyer someplace looking for business
if that
there you go now of course it's not
really the truth as you might expect
we've looked at the polling uh track
record for desantis's uh election and
um in fact
it was months after Trump's endorsement
that DeSantis started gaining in the
polls so it wasn't exactly the explosive
rocket ship that Trump wants you to
believe it to be
extraordinarily disturbingly Donald
Trump said that he would appoint if he
became president and had the opportunity
he would appoint more Supreme Court
Justices like Clarence Thomas he says
Clarence Thomas is under siege for for
no good reason of course it's very scary
to think that you look at the Supreme
Court and you say oh we need more people
like Clarence Thomas
thank you
I will appoint Rock Solid constitutional
conservative judges in the mold of
Justice Antonin Scalia and the great
Justice Clarence Thomas who is under
siege right now right
he's under siege right now
for doing nothing
he is really they're going after him
right now he's right about Thomas is
doing nothing he hasn't spoken on the
court for Allah everybody else talked
about appointing conservatives to court
I am the only one who actually did it I
appointed almost 300
federal judges all told it was
pretty substantially more than that a
record and three great Supreme Court
Justices so that was a big that was a
big thing
that was big so of course horrifying to
hear as we learned that uh Clarence
Thomas is likely the most corrupt and
unethical Supreme Court Justice in a
hundred years that Trump says we need
more people like Clarence Thomas and
this is of course the weaponized
contrarianism contrarianism for the sake
of contrarianism that has become a
Hallmark of the modern Maga movement
Donald Trump also doing this routine
where he says he will
um try to get DA's and Attorneys General
fired based on essentially their
political orientation
[Applause]
stop the local Marxist prosecutors who
release rapists and murderers while
persecuting conservatives on day one of
my new Administration I will direct the
doj to investigate every radical D.A and
attorney general in America for their
radical according to whom illegal racist
in Reverse enforcement of the law
a genuinely deranged and dangerous idea
and understand that Trump wants if Trump
had his way
he would get rid of any federal
government employee that simply didn't
vote for him even if they are
non-political Trump that this is one of
Trump's big big Crusades he wants to be
able to fire everyone and replace them
with loyalists even in bureaucratic
positions where politics really
shouldn't make a difference and he wants
to do the same thing with DA's and
Attorneys General not going to happen by
the way just completely absurd but it's
not going to happen Trump also going
after his own former Attorney General
William Barr criticizing him the bill
Barr had any courage instead of worrying
about being impeached by the Democrats
these people would have all been taken
care of but we have to do it a different
way if he had courage we need people
with courage he had no courage he didn't
want to be impeached sure I don't want
to be impeached
I said what's wrong with being impeached
I got impeached twice and my numbers
went up
he wasn't he wasn't a brave person
[Applause]
now he sits back and pontificates it's
all Trump do so Trump that the man
didn't have courage he didn't have
courage to go out and do what you had to
do with respect to the election yeah and
of course who hired him it was Trump
trump ran on I will hire the best people
and he ended up hiring some of the worst
people even by his own admission Trump's
delusions of grandeur certainly didn't
slow down at all claiming that when he
won in 2016 not only did he save the
country he says he also saved the
Republican Party good point
to put it simply on Election Day 2016 we
didn't just save America we saved the
Republican party we did
hard to believe really given the
shambles that the Republican Party finds
itself in today Trump continuing the
delusions by saying he's probably the
most honest person who has ever been
president even more honest than Honest
Abe there's no crime
I got indicted for no crime
they were all saying even the Democrats
well we don't see this
you know a friend of mine said you
probably the most honest person to ever
be president
and then capping off a completely insane
evening Donald Trump then stopping at a
pizza place and taking a bite out of a
slice and asking whether anyone wants
the slice that Trump took a bite out of
[Music]
anybody
[Applause]
[Music]
and of course they cheer it is indeed a
cult many of them wanting a slice that
Donald Trump took a bite out of so this
is going to be the next year I hate to
inform people that that this is what
American politics will be like meanwhile
hopefully President Joe Biden will keep
accomplishing things and uh I think for
that we we should really encourage that
Donald Trump speaking this afternoon in
New Hampshire at what I'm certain will
be a very unhinged campaign event we
will cover it live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook
um but do not be confused this is indeed
a cult we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P you know a lot of
people were concerned about my hair
yesterday saying David you know are you
are you having an alcohol problem are
you having something going on in your
life where your grooming is really
falling apart because sometimes when
people are struggling their grooming
suffers and indeed here is someone who
called in about the cowlick
that's from Boston um
please watching the show as usual it's
great as usual
and as usual you've got some giant
cowlick
jutting up from the back of the right
side of your head yes
um
you know it is what it is I'm just
wondering like what what is going on
with your hair
um
it's just it's just I'm watching I'm
trying to watch the show it's just
vaguely distracting yeah so a lot of
people wrote To Me concerned here's
what's going on okay it's getting nice
out
and it's late the light is out there's
light until late in the day and so very
often I'm not getting the opportunity to
shower until 9 pm
and it's forcing me to go to bed with
wet hair
and then I wake up and it's a complete
and total mess and I understand that it
seems as though something really bad
must be going on for this to be
happening my grooming just suffering so
much but it's basically like with my
baby daughter's schedule and then you
know sometimes we'll we'll go out for a
drink and then it becomes 7 30 and then
it you know we go through bedtime
routine and then dinner and by the time
I'm able to shower it's nine and I'm
trying to get in bed by 10 15 these days
and get an earlier start so I'm going to
bed with wet hair now I know you could
say well David you could just use a blow
dryer I don't know how to use a blow
dryer so that's the problem with that
but everything is fine it's not an
alcohol related issue it's not anything
it's not an emotional issue I'm just
going to bed with wet hair because of my
schedule now that it's nice out
and that is what it is but I'll try to
keep things under better control on the
bonus show today we'll talk about what's
going on with Stephen Crowder so many of
you writing to me we will discuss it we
will talk about the trans lawmaker
censured by the Montana House
Republicans we will talk about what's
going on with the founder of the we
build the wall scam group he got four
years in prison and so much more make
sure you have access to the bonus show
by signing up at joinpakman.com
foreign